到底大看POMO會不會在AI POMO?
你的AI是從個人、家庭、社會
就一路全面性的
都在影響你的不管你的生產力也好
或者是你的生活也好
你的學習
其實你生活的方方面面
工作的方方面面
社會的方方面面
幾乎都衝擊到了
航空布拉格 商務艙 雙人機票等你抽
心動不如行動 火速開戶做任務囉
各位觀眾大家好 我是主持人Nora
歡迎收看今天不聊股票
今天我們真的不聊股票
因為今天要聊的是比股票漲跌更重要的未來趨勢
今天我們邀請的來賓是企業公認數位轉型領航員
數位轉型學院的院長 詹文南老師
主持人好 各位觀眾好
非常開心有這個機會來上今天不聊股票
因為老師經歷非常的豐富
請老師可不可以稍微簡單的介紹一下
您過去的豐富的經歷呢
主持人這樣問我
其實讓我有點為難
因為講太好大家不太相信
講得不太好又覺得說
這個人請來幹嘛這樣子
所以我還是先講一下
我現在在幹嘛好了
我是張文南
我在臺大商業所跟政大EMBA教書
那這是我這五年的主要的工作
但是我五年前呢
等於說我的職業生涯
過去三十年
是在資策會產業情報研究所
我們稱為資策會MIC
擔任所長的工作
那這個機構呢
是經濟部底下的財政法人
也就是智庫
那主要的服務就是政府機構跟民間
擔任這個像經濟部啊
國發會啊
甚至行政院總統府啊
就是他們我們在
在破壞未來的產業政策的時候
我們大概有將近300個同仁
在做高科技產業的研究
因為要研究這個產業趨勢
所以我們有掌握到一些市場的變化
因此我們會把這些情報資訊
提供給產業界
所以我們也擔任產業顧問的工作
所以在我過去主要的生涯
就是政府智庫跟產業顧問
這樣子的一個主要的任務跟角色
首先我們想問問院長
那其實AI的發展已經超過70年了
從這個1956年開始定義AI這個名詞開始
那到了2016年
其實那個AlphaGo全部人都在看
它打敗了就是世界的那個奇王李適時
然後再到2022年
這個Chad GPT橫空而逝
那以前我們在看這個AI就覺得
好像在看戲很好玩
它到底能不能打敗人類了
那它出來之後呢
那我們想說為什麼這一次
AI真的是好像
動到了人類的腦袋的部分
剛剛主持人提到說
AI其實不是這幾年才出世的
就是已經七八十年的
這樣子的一個歷史
但是過去起起伏伏
也就是說過去大家就想說
能不能有一個機器或系統
可以像專家一樣
能夠回答我們的問題
然後更進一步的可以協助我們
解決很多這樣子的一個產業上
或者是生活上的一些議題
可是我們發現說
在過去因為技術還沒有到位
所以沒有辦法做到那樣的程度
在2016年剛剛Nora提到了說
基本上AI打敗理事時
這個AlphaGo
可是因為它究竟是在下圍棋
我常常在上課的時候
就問很多的產業界的人士說
請問一下在座會下圍棋的人多不多
你會不會下圍棋
不會
大部分人都不會下圍棋
所以一個AlphaGo AI打敗危機高手
其實跟我們生活上是沒什麼關係的
但是2022年的這樣的GBT出來之後
這個生存式AI
它影響的可真的是很深遠
就是我們過去發現說
這個機器取代體力這件事情是藍領的
但是生存式AI這一次是白領的
而且是各行各業
因為它會寫文章
會做音樂
然後會寫程式拍影片等等
你就發現說各行各業都受到很大的衝擊
所以大家才會開始覺得說
哎呦我的天啊
我以前這樣子
我們比如說我們念大學唸了四年
然後現在的AI已經有博士程度了
那我會不會被它取代
所以焦慮感主要是來自於這個部分
因為它的能力還在持續持續的在提升
我每天每天用它
我就覺得說哇Amazing
竟然還可以做到這樣的程度
沒錯沒錯
像老師之前有提到
以前的AI或是智慧的話
它只是一些體力跟感知的一些取代
譬如說在工廠做一些瑕疵的檢驗而已
但是現在我們發現不一樣了
包含這2025年AI
它如果參加奧林匹克跟城市的競賽
它其實可以達到金獎的
甚至參加美國SAT考試的話
它應該可以到99%的百分比
應該可以上頂大了吧
哈佛 史丹佛都可以
這都沒有問題了
所以以往這些專業人士
他影響的應該不是隻一般
專業人士他有個專業知識的護城河
那這些AI會帶來他們什麼樣的一些衝擊呢
是就是剛剛主任提到
因為他這些專業知識
因為他已經到博士的程度
而且是在各專業裡面
剛剛講在大陸
像是AI已經可以清大北大
這絕對沒問題了
美國剛剛提到
這個城市比賽是冠軍
然後數學奧林匹亞都是金牌
所以他的能力已經到這樣子的一個程度了
所以本來專業人士
他說靠他的知識
靠他的經驗這些
恐怕可能在未來有了AI之後
可能都無永無之地
所以很多人就很擔心說
那我現在怎麼辦
所以剛剛Nora提到說
所謂的護城河
所以我們就要去了解一下說
深圳市AI
現在目前的進展的狀況是如何
哪些他可以做 擅長做
那我們就不要去跟他競爭
我們是去運用他
然後我們就把我們
應該要做的
比他擅長的
哪些呢
比如說第一個
我們其實要有
所謂的提問的能力
因為你沒有問他
他不會自己告訴你
他要做什麼
對不對
所以提問能力就非常重要
好
提問能力還包含
另外一個能力
就是定義問題的能力
比如說我們現在
要解決什麼問題
產業有什麼樣的痛點
企業上面有遇到什麼瓶頸
這個部分
你需要有一個完整的瞭解
比如說我現在在富邦證券
我比較知道說
富邦證券的一些脈絡
過去的發展
未來想要做到什麼程度
因此我在提問的時候
我定義問題的時候
就會比較清楚說
當然比AI知道說
因為我問AI說
富邦正月將來要做什麼
我想他一定亂打一通
因為他不知道過去
也不知道未來對不對
所以提問跟定義問題
這是第一個非常重要
你必須要努力去提升的
第二個是
當你問了問題之後
他不是會回答很多事情嗎
可能他都亂回答
甚至有一些虛幻
所以你就必須要有辨識的能力
他到底講的對不對
然後有沒有道理
這個部分你要有能力來駕馭他
就是辨識他
所以這是第二個
你應該要具備的能力
第三個其實AI也沒有的
我們叫做遇到的一些
比較困難複雜的問題的時候
舉例來講
我要不要裁員
我不是講富邦證券
我是說在傳統產業
如果遇到AI問題
那我要不要裁員呢
那我短期長期
它之間的權衡又是如何呢
那你的價值觀
就是在做取捨的時候
它的價值觀
或者在這種人際互動的判斷
這個AI也做不到
所以這個也是人
必須要去keep的部分
那當然最後就是
要承擔責任
因為AI沒辦法承擔責任
它做出來的東西
只能提供你參考
最後的責任
還是你要承擔
所以是這幾個部分
是我們知道AI是做不到
但是人是可以駕馭AI的一個非常重要的元素
理解我們剛剛聽到老師說了
其實AI對專業人士他其實是有衝擊的
但是我們就不要跟他硬拼
所以我們應該在他達不到的地方
我們用我們自己的能力去補足
那我們發現AI在航空產事的部分
他其實自己那個人跟他的角色是不是有點變化
從一開始他也許我們只是工具而已
那現在好像就是有一些美國青少年
他回家之後可能秘密不跟爸爸媽媽講
是跟他講的
他變成好像是不是一個親密朋友的角色
閨蜜
那26年呢
老師說你可能覺得他也會變成是
我們同事了
那這個AI的角色
我們要怎麼去用它
可以重塑我們在職場上
工作人員的這些競爭力呢
對 剛剛諾爾提到一個非常重要的
就是說我們剛提到說
他對這個專業人士是有非常重擊
但是我們不要跟他競爭
我們不僅不要跟他競爭
甚至要利用他來提升我們的能力
比如說在AI他的這樣子的一個
非常Powerful的能力之下
其實你要去能夠教育他
比如說你現在能力是100分
但是藉由AI你可能就可以到1000分
所以怎麼樣去透過AI來賦能你
賦能你的同事
這個是非常重要的
另外一個問題就是剛Nora提到的說
從趨勢演變我們來看說
剛提到的AI本來是工具
大家利用它來想創意 寫文章
提升我的程式的寫作的生產力等等
這是工具
可是我們發現說
AI在聊天的過程當中
它因為技術的進步
就越來越瞭解你
然後甚至在跟你對談的過程中
我們知道說最近的技術
這個GPT Live
你會發現
幾乎跟你聊天的時候
還會稍微停頓一下
然後還會跟你講
像我剛剛來的時候
還跟AI在講臺語這樣
然後我說你會不會講臺語
他還講說我不會說
然後他只會講講一點點
然後我說你怎麼樣去努力學這個
他說你只要教我
我就會慢慢的學會這樣子
就是說他在跟你對話的時候
這個因為技術進步
就會更流暢
就真的像你的閨蜜
我有一個EMBA的學生
他就說他有一次被老闆罵
他很生氣
因為他覺得不是我的錯
然後回來的時候
就跟AI聊了三個30分鐘
沒想到AI真的提供滿滿的情緒價值
最後還跟他講說
你不要感覺到生氣
我永遠都會在你旁邊陪著你
他好感動
回去跟他先生講
他先生還吃醋了
你就知道說他真的是成為一個閨蜜
接下來我們說要成為分身
因為現在AI agent已經越來越成熟了
而且進步非常快
所以我記得有一次去參加一個
人力廠商的演講
我就看到他們的slogan就是
就是我的同事不是人
為什麼呢 是AI嘛
所以將來會有你很多的數位同事
那當然我後來是寫另外一篇
我也寫了一篇文章叫做
我的主管不是人
你有感覺對不對
我的主管真的不是人
以後會不會是我的老師也不是人
有可能
我剛講是還沒有AI的時候
你們心裡是不是覺得我的主管不是人
但是我都覺得我那時候
我的主管是超人
跟你講的不太一樣
老師你這樣對了
我的老闆我現在要證明說也是超人
剛剛提到了說因為我主管不是人
他是個agent之後
你就要想你的能力又要變成提升了
黃仁鑫說他公司有72000人
他希望一個人可以管100個agent
這樣的話就是等於公司有720萬人
所以你的能力要變成什麼
當你手下有100個人
我譬如說我們是個年輕人
剛進一家公司
比如說富邦證券好了一個人
結果他要管100個數位同事
那他會不會管
就是他怎麼樣去定義問題
分解任務
讓不同的agent去做他的事情
然後再協調這些agent
完成公司所交付的任務
這又變成他需要提升的能力了
所以剛講的管agent
又是將來必備的一個能力
理解理解
那剛剛從對於人的衝擊
那我們也談到了一點點的
關於企業的數位轉型
那我們現在就來談談
就是企業怎麼去用AI
那之前也知道就是像BCG
他也調查過1萬個這個員工
他說AI就已經變成是
主管跟經理人日常生活
工作的一個一部分了
那McKinsey也說了
88%的這個組織
至少在一個企業功能項目裡面
會使用AI
而且剛剛老師提到
這個代理agent的部分的話
其實也有大概23%的組織
也開始在用了
所以如果我們在做
就是企業轉型的話
之前老師有提到
就是我們大家可能熟知的
傳統故事叫周楚雛三害
可是大家知道這是歷史故事
但是不知道說到底周楚雛三害
跟我們的AI數位轉型
到底有什麼關係
那三害到底是哪三害
老師可不可以稍微說明一下
因為最近有幾部電影
有一部電影叫周楚雛三害
結果那個是一個通緝犯
到處殺人的故事
可是因為票房非常高
所以很多人以為周楚雛三害是這個
其實不是
我剛談的週五除暗愛
主要是古時候有一位流氓
地方流氓
然後他有時候就到處閒閒
然後欺負地方老百姓
搞得大家惶惶不安
結果有一次他就問旁邊一個老婆婆
因為他也閒來無聊
說你覺得你現在最大的困擾是什麼
那老婆婆說北山有猛虎
然後南海有角龍
就造成我們整個鄉鎮都不安寧
因為他還蠻有正義感的
他就開始去北山
真的把那個門戶給斬了
然後還到南海把那個角龍給他斬了
那就是傷害
後來他就問他說
那還有什麼困擾
你不是說三大困擾嗎
他說還有困擾就是你
原來他就是地痞流氓
那個老婆婆講了這個直白話之後
他誠心懺悔
覺得應該把自己提升
然後後來就當到大官了
就是因為他不斷的自我提升
洗心革面
然後重新改造自己
這跟企業的數位轉型
跟AI轉型有什麼關係
就是我們在企業裡面
要做數位轉型
或做AI轉型
第一步一定是老闆要先洗心革面
也就是說老闆要以身作則
然後要了解AI的大的趨勢
然後知道AI可以做什麼
AI不可以做什麼
然後怎麼樣去帶領
全公司往前邁進
這個是第一步非常重要
所以我才會說你要AI轉型
第一步一定是周處除傷害
把自己也要把它除掉
就是變成一個嶄新的自己
這個非常重要
所以我們以前在唸管理
最重要的就是問題全在前三排
根源就在主席臺
管理上的問題就是這個
非常好的
就是老闆其實都是很多問題的根源
但我老闆現在是超人
是
你老闆比較不一樣
我會跟董事長講一下
我剛剛提到的說
你能不能自我提升
然後對AI的趨勢的掌握
這是第一步
所以我才說周楚楚三派
第一個就是從自己開始
然後自己要有覺醒
第二步就是
當我自我覺醒了之後
我要開始去了解
整個AI的變化的時候
那就要去看外在形勢
到底有產生哪些改變
舉例來說
比如說現在社會
技術
政治
我剛剛講的社會
我們現在大的社會的變化
比如說我們說講高齡化
這次大趨勢要掌握到燒紙
然後技術就是AI
然後政治 地緣政治現在影響社會很多
就是要把這些大的趨勢瞭解的時候
那我們就要看看說
在這個大趨勢底下
我們自己有什麼樣的機會
有什麼樣的挑戰
好 在這個機會跟挑戰之下
那我們應該怎麼樣來做我們的數位轉型
這是第二步
第三步就是
那我們要怎麼來做數位轉型
在我們定目標之前
我們一定要先做幾個事情
第一個我們先去看看我們同業
或者是世界上的標竿
或者我這個人
我這個行業是獨一無二的
那我就去看別的行業
跟我們很類似的
那這麼做數位轉型 AI轉型
做到什麼程度
因為臺灣的廠商
廠商也有一個現象
就是不敢自己做
開始就做 花錢做
因為怕做不好
所以就會想說
如果你有一個參考座標的話
你就會比較安心一些
好 那有了參考座標的時候
就來看看自己有沒有什麼樣的痛點
那可以要解決的
然後排優先順序
因為一個人痛點一定很多
不是單一
那我們怎麼樣去找到那種
可能影響我們最大的
我常跟同學分享
就是我們的目標一定是
收入極大化
成本極小化
你是說怎麼樣能夠賺錢
怎麼樣能夠節省成本
在這個情況之下去選擇
我們要開始優先順序上
應該要做的一個項目
然後開始去執行
那剛剛老師也大概分享了
如果數位要轉型的話
第一個其實要周除除傷害
那我想臺灣其實也有蠻多的傳統企業
其實開始慢慢就是真的有除了傷害了
開始擁抱AI了
那我們想來聊一聊這些傳統企業的實力
那聽說臺灣有一個公廟
它很神奇
它的那個牽絲還是用AI解的
老師要不要來幫大家分享一下
這幾年我們知道說這個AI運用
在各行各業都有在運用
比如說一級產業
我們所謂的一級產業就是農林與牧獵
大家知道說養豬 養牛 養魚
基本上現在都在用AI
連種鳳梨 種稻都是
第二種就是我們所謂的工業
二級產業就製造業
剛剛有提到瑕疵檢測
或者是說設備
我只要聽聲音
我大概就知道說有什麼問題
製造業用很多
接下來就服務業
服務業現在比如說無人商店
所以無人商店不是沒有人來搞關商店
就是說他沒有服務員
然後你都用Kiosk
後臺來準備這些餐點
現在這種自動化也非常多
甚至用AI點餐
比如說你如果是美國人
就跟他用英文對話
然後就可以用英文點餐
用日文用韓文都可以
所以這個部分的應用
也非常的廣泛
可是我們發現說
也有一個行業是最傳統的行業
就是宮廟業
沒想到也有人用AI用得很好
我舉一個例在北港
這是雲林
雲林縣北港
有一個武德宮
就是臺灣最大的財神廟
他上次去了解了一下
我覺得真不簡單
他至少在AI上面有做了幾件事情
我覺得很值得跟大家分享
第一個他為什麼開始要用AI
是因為主委跟我講
主委是我們政大的校友
他是臺大經濟系
政大金融研究所的高材生
他回去接
我這樣開玩笑說
好像也是二代接班
他其實是三代接班
因為那是外公那時候
這個來起的廟這樣子
有一天他看到一個報紙說
比如說2025年
全省的十大景點就有哪些
朝天宮什麼大甲正南宮什麼這些廟
竟然沒有他
他就覺得很奇怪
他的人也很多
就是姓仲
陳勝業的姓仲很多
為什麼沒有他的名字
就是他去了解
原來政府是說
你要去自己去數
計數說
大概有多少人來看
人流多少
然後上去報
確認了有這些證據了
然後他就會把他排進來說
第一名是舉例來說
我這也是舉例
比如說朝天宮大概有700萬人一年
然後人大概多少人
然後他想說
那我也要去報名
就是讓大家瞭解說
其實產生信眾也非常多
可是要用什麼來計數呢
怎麼不能找一個人在那邊按那個
這樣也是太傳統了
因為後來他就想說
那可以用AI來計數
所以他就弄一個攝影機
就開始去算人流
因為你知道嗎
所謂的人流是
我進去走出來
你要算幾個人
同一個人
所以你進去出來
如果是同一個人的話
你要算一個人
你不能算兩個人
那我這樣進去出出
不是你能算很多次嗎
所以要算一個人
所以他要去辨識
說是這個人進去
然後這個人出來
然後就是同一個人
所以他每天算
他可以辨識人臉就對了
對 辨識到說
今天大概有30萬人來
類似這樣
那一年大概就有六七百萬
這樣子人次這樣
所以他有一年是
這個全省是第一名的
但是基本上都是在前五名之內的
那用了AI之後
因為AI有很大的算力
大家想說
那在他的整個營運日常當中
還有什麼東西需要用到AI
他就發現說
你知道廟裡面有很多的火燭
就是比如說有大的蠟燭
有人拿的香
有時候喝咖啡也有茶的煙
他就想說我其實很怕這種火災
所以他就也是一樣
用我們叫AI門神
他把它取名就是去辨識煙
如果火稍微大一點
趕快耳熱
然後通知消防隊
今年年初就是2020年初
就是有一個行動電源突然燒起來
也是這個AI門神去看到它
所以趕快通知消防隊
才沒有亮成大的災禍
就用債防債這是第二個
第三個它發現說
這個好像需要用到
因為有時候要解簽
我們慶仲如果說要解簽
然後看了那個就是去求簽
求了之後看不懂那怎麼辦
都文言文啊
然後就用AI幫你解釋
有一個籤文還蠻有意思的
有人要去投資
雖然我們今天不聊投資
但是發現他信中要去想要all in
然後去抽
竟然是下下籤
那怎麼辦呢
怎麼解讀呢
那後來他就說
你這個是下下籤
表示有很多困難跟挑戰
你會發現他解籤的內容
他是結合了投資學管理學
跟是策略管理的知識
除了解釋那個籤文之外
還運用這些理論跟知識
來告訴信眾
你投資一定有風險
股市有賺有賠
對對對
請審慎評估
審慎評估
他在這個裡面都有含在說明
所以這個解籤蠻厲害的
真的
在第三個
他是用這個AI來解軟文
你知道那個神明降價
在傳統的民俗裡面
有一種是神明降價的時候
會請那個軟身用筆寫
有時候看那個很慢
那時候顧客體驗就不好
因為大家等了很久
神明到底講了什麼事情
他們就覺得說把過去30年的
寫的這個軟文把它全部建檔
然後用AI來辨識
那這樣子的話
這個軟身寫完之後
筆聲寫完之後
就可以馬上知道說
神明到底是在講什麼
效率就會提高很多
提升效率
所以說他們運用AI真的是無微不至
非常的廣泛
甚至寫新聞稿
我覺得他們還有很多的創新
甚至他們連虎爺
他把它變成很Q版的存錢筒
而他存錢筒的材質
有一半是香灰
就是他的材質香灰
就是提供的香灰
所以也是循環經濟
甚至前兩年
他已經是成為
全球第一家碳中和的公廟
因為他買了一些碳泉
希望能夠做到碳中和
所以其實這個觀念上是非常先進
在科技應用上面也是非常的open
這是這個廟宇的案例
我覺得為什麼要舉這個案例
即使這麼傳統的行業
都能夠用AI用得這麼好
我就覺得這個很不簡單
這個案子真的是讓我們覺得非常的impressive
我們認為真的是最傳統的宮廟的部分
竟然可以把AI用得這麼的徹底
對 真的是很難得
那我們就再聊一聊一個
還有一個它也是傳統業
它是麵包店
它是益智軒
那聽說他也用了AI
讓這個員工訓練時間也有大幅縮短
那也縮短了他的結帳時間
老師要不要聊一聊
我們剛剛講一二三級產業
那個三級產業這個麵包
大家知道說那個麵包大小不一樣
這個很多的麵包你要寄
它也不能貼個條碼對不對
或是標籤在上面對不對
所以有時候就要靠
每個店員這邊寄說
這個麵包多少錢
然後結帳這樣
後來他們就覺得說
這樣子速度很慢
為什麼
因為第一個
你要讓店員要寄這麼多種的麵包
因為每天的麵包
有時候出爐又不一樣
然後再來
假設店員流動率高的話
要重新訓練一遍
要花很多時間
所以他們就想說
是不是能夠把這些routine的
然後大家遇到的一些
比較困難複雜的事情
都交給AI做
舉例來說
客人拿著一盤麵包
就放在攝影機底下一照
大概就知道這家多少錢了
所以速度就變得很快了
他也不用去計
人做什麼呢
介紹新商品
然後保留這種溫度
人與人之間的互動
等於說我們剛剛不是提到說
人可以做什麼嗎
這AI就做不到
就是人計的互動
提供溫度溫暖這樣
這個其實在一支圈上面
就可以看到這樣子的一個範例
就人適合做什麼
AI適合做什麼
對他就是把可能比較作業面的事情
交由AI來處理
那把主動的銷售跟給予溫暖的部分的話
就由人來做這個主要的這個的作業的部分
對其實是非常聰明的
好那雖然後我們講到就是今天那個不聊股票
但是呢
來就是關注我們富邦證券的頻道的很多的網友
其實還是蠻喜歡投資這個話題的
對對對
所以大家其實之前
常常都會有一個疑問
就是現在AI這麼的熱
其實它到底是一個真的趨勢
其實市場上
還是有很多的雜訊在討論
老師要不要跟大家分享一下
一般的投資人
有沒有什麼樣的方法
讓這些投資大眾可以分辨
到底這個是真趨勢
還是是一個假議題呢
我在臺南商業所
跟政大EMBS交產業分析
我想產業分析其實是投資的最基本面
因為我們知道說在投資裡面有什麼籌碼面
還有什麼技術面還有消息面
我們就是三面
以前我還開玩笑說什麼上影線下影線都不如一條內線
這就是消息面
我們這是基本面產業分析
產業分析就是說這個產業到底未來會長成什麼樣子
我們就是在做這個部分
所以我們做智庫或者做產業顧問
就是在提供產業的大趨勢
舉例來說
比如說我們現在是2026年
我們已經在幫政府估計說
2035年會發生什麼事情
然後現在應該怎麼樣子來準備
這些事情很多學生都會問我說
老師未來怎麼可能預測
比如現在是2026年
那怎麼可能到2035年是怎麼樣
誰預測得了
我就問他一個問題
就有一個年輕的學生
他30歲
我就說你現在幾歲
他說30歲
我說我大膽預測
50年後
如果中間你沒掛掉的話
應該80歲對不對
是這有沒有錯
沒錯嘛對吧
這很精確
所以其實大家常講說
能不能預測都是在預測
不可預測那一塊
比如說兩岸會不會打起來
然後或是剛提到的
八級地震會不會來
這個沒有人可以預測
但是有一些是很容易預測的
舉例來說
我不確定明天我會不會更好
但我確定我明天一定會更老
你是不是這樣子
所以你現在應該
主持人現在應該是
這輩子最年輕的時候
在這個時候
謝謝老師
所以有利於是
我們如果能夠掌握到一些
可預測的部分
尤其是人口統計變數
舉例來說
我們從2025年開始
臺灣就有20%是65歲以上的人
那你看這一塊首齡經濟
帶來的食衣住行娛樂市場需求
有多大呢
對不對
再我舉另外一個例子
我常跟同學分享說
我們在做那個長期研究的時候
就看到一個9034現象
就90後出生的女生
三成會沒有子女
四成會沒有孫子女
那如果三成沒有子女的話
他是怎麼算
其實很好算
兩成的女生現在不婚
不婚會不會有小孩
不會
或者是任養
不一定
所以可能三四%有小孩
所以16%沒有小孩
然後結婚的女生
其中有兩層
不生不想生
不願意生不能生
最後沒有生
所以剛講了
有八層
二八十六
十六加十六就三十二
所以903
就是90後出生的女生
三層會沒有子女
那以這樣子的比例
往下推算的話
這些90後的
就有四層會沒有孫子女
那你是不是看到一個現象說
那如果你沒有子女 沒有孫子女的話
你會把錢花在什麼地方
你就這樣想
所以市場推估就會出現
所以我們看趨勢
就是剛剛提到的
我們把可預測的先把它掌握住
如果不可預測
我們就用scenario情境分析
從方法論的來講
就是你要看未來
並不是沒有方法
剛剛提到的
我們把可預測的都把它掌握
可預測的方法論裡面
第一個當然就是剛剛數字推
是不是推
就剛剛提到9034
或者是2030年
你知道臺灣的平均年齡大概幾歲
大概有一半人口是49歲以上
大概50歲
也就是說你想想看
你覺得50歲老不老
現在好像還好
但是以前我看我媽媽
和我爸爸50歲
覺得好像已經
因為金庸小說
我們小時候看金庸小說
前面來了一位五旬老者
就是老者
五旬老者
但是現在不是
50歲就是很年前
可是剛剛講了50歲以上
他有錢有錢
尤其是65歲以上
所以你就可以怎麼樣去掌握這塊市場
我的意思是說
其實當我們在預測未來的時候
先把可以掌握的先預測
所以回到你剛剛提到的大的趨勢
我們看到社會的一些面向
我們就會用2M2C來分析
2M2C 什麼叫2M2C
第一個M就是Macro 總體環境
這個總體環境也很簡單
就五個字
STEEP
S就是社會環境
價值觀 剛提到了我們說
現在的高齡 少子化
甚至9034現象
剛剛講9034現象
女生如果有很多錢
但沒有子女她花在什麼地方
花在自己 更漂亮對不對
更動力 或者養寵物等等
這就是社會S
T就是技術
技術將來有什麼大的變化
尤其是科技 AI
甚至生技方面的技術
再來E就是經濟
另外一個E就是Ecology
生態 環境
最後是Political
就是我們所謂的地緣政治
所以這把這五個面向好好掌握住
STEP
你就大的趨勢大概就掌握到了
第二個M是Market
比如說我是製造業
我是金屬業
那我就要針對這個金屬行業的
大的趨勢去掌握
那我們都有一套方法論
那如果要來上課的話
政大業也歡迎加入
好再來就是C
兩個C
第一個是Customer
就是客戶
我的客戶呢
比如他需要什麼
在哪裡需要
願意付多少錢
這是第一個C
第二個是competitor
我的競爭者
所以2M2C
我通常在分析外在的形式的時候
這2M2C要加另外一C
company
就是我自己
我自己外在形式瞭解了
我要對自己能力有所掌握
人家說
沒在專心點
我要三對一點
一定要定量自己的狀況
來決定哪一個是
比如說我需不需要開槓杆
然後要開多幾倍
類似這樣
這個是大致上的一個分析的手法
我覺得剛剛老師已經分享了很多
非常精闢的方法論
那幾乎想這個是
真的是老師沒有保留的
滿滿的分享的部分
平常可能是要上課才能夠
真的
才可以得到的
但是我還是要替一下
替我們喜歡投資的網友
我還是要問一下
因為大家目前來講的話
AI其實是蠻熱的
那大家也會想到就是其實2000年有一個.com的泡沫
那現在的話我們在想說大家都在瘋投資
那到底呢我們在這個AI的這個投資裡面
我們投資人是應該要投資那個賣產值的那個人
還是真正靠AI賺錢的人呢
到底是做AI基建比較有機會
還是把AI這個工具拿來賺錢的比較有機會
可能也不能這樣分
大部分人說我們要投資這個賣產值的人
這原則上是對的
不過我覺得我們看趨勢
也不能這樣看
就是說你還是要全面的關照
在我去參加某個音樂會的時候
有一個金空的總經理
看到我就說
張老師
從小就是看你的報告長大了
我嚇一跳
我說我看他也不太老
為什麼這樣講
他說他年輕的時候
就在徵信室做產業研究
所以他常常看
因為我也是從年輕的時候
就寫研究報告長大的
所以他就看到我的報告
他第一句話就說
詹老師這個很難得遇見你
我請教你一下
你覺得AI會不會泡沫
我第一句話就問他
我說AI會不會泡沫
按照我們產業分析的第一個原則
先要定義清楚你的問題
請問你認為什麼是泡沫
就是你要問我的泡沫是指什麼意思
舉例來講是股價修正
還是說所有的公司都會倒
然後AI就不見了
是舉例是這樣子
我說他想想說
對沒錯有道理
意思就是說
其實我們在問問題的時候
一定要把定義內涵搞清楚
這時候我們要回答的時候
才能夠針對這樣子回答
所以回答剛剛Nora提到的問題
就是說
那到底大看泡沫會不會在AI泡沫
我們其實我們發現說
大看泡沫其實也是幾年
但是慢慢的你就會發現說
Internet互聯網已經變成
大家每天的生活
現在是每天了
那AI更是如此
而且我覺得它的影響可能更為深遠
為什麼這樣說呢
因為Internet是你的生活日常
但是你會發現說你的AI
是從個人 家庭 社會
就一路全面性的
都在影響你的
不管你的生產力也好
或者是你的生活也好
你的學習
就你生活的方方面面
工作的方方面面
社會的方方面面
幾乎都衝擊到了
所以它是一個
絕對是一個大的趨勢
甚至我都覺得它應該是
我們常常想說
第三次工業革命是電腦
那第四次應該就是這個AI
就是這個AI
當然有人提到說那個基因也是
那是另外一個issue
我發現說AI可能也會讓這個
我們基因革命會加速
好那我們就剛提到的
它可能是一個很全面性的工業革命
也因此它絕對不會是泡沫
那我剛剛講說
為什麼我說你要去定義你的泡沫呢
我們說這個股價一定會修正
因為總是有些是很砰砰的
我不知道我常常聽到名嘴講
什麼腰骨
就是說基本上你會覺得說
他的本益比沒有正常的現金流
然後也沒成長很多
我最近看到一個資料說
如果有一家公司
他的營收都一直衰退
但毛利一直增加
會不會有這樣的公司
你會不會覺得他怪怪的
然後你就要去看這個事情
剛剛提到到底是賣產值
還是掏金的
其實你這樣想
我們說在AI時代
黃榮鑫講五層蛋糕
對不對
從能源開始
然後晶片
然後就是像GPU
然後有大模型
有server
最後應用
事實上都有可以牢緊的地方
也就是說都有他的
可能賺錢的標的
什麼意思呢
因為比如說能源好了
現在肌肉這麼大
那當然能源股就往上走
然後黃榮鑫GPU
GPU現在很多人為了要訓練AI的模型
所以GPU TPU什麼都開始陸陸續續的在推展
然後再來AI Server
臺灣因為這幾年AI Server成長得非常快
然後之後就平臺大模型
然後再來就是模型上面的很多的應用
所以在這五層蛋糕裡面
事實上都有機會有廠商可以勝出
我們要怎麼去評估呢
其實第一個它是不是走在大的趨勢上
大家發現說
大家的確都走在AI區域上
可是我們接下來就分辨了
它到底是不是有
我們常常講真金白銀
我們說它到底有什麼競爭優勢
而這個競爭優勢是非常獨特
別人沒有的
現在大家看到最大的問題
就是說它沒有正常
或者是說夠多的現金流
來支撐它很多的投資
在這個情況下
你就要去審慎評估
說它未來是不是有可能
在這些他的前提假設上面
不斷的往前走
那最近我印象大家最印象深刻的
應該就是SpaceX對不對
那上去之後就下來了
現在破方了
就是你會發現說
原來他的理想是很好
但是可能還沒有到達
可以實現的那樣子的一個境地
所以就下來了
但是他是不是一個未來
是 對 是個未來
所以我說在這個層次上面
要這樣子分析
你就會比較清楚
那我們一般來評價一下
這家公司我們這個產業分析
我也有跟同學分享
第一個當然是符合大的產業趨勢
第二個就是你在這個趨勢上面
可是有沒有獨特的競爭優勢
是別人沒有的
我們就剛剛主持人問的什麼
護城河
你這護城河有沒有比別人更厲害
厲害多少
然後他是不是長期可以厲害
這是第二個
第三個就看這個經營團隊
這個經營團隊到底是真的走長期的
還是想撈了一票就跑了
這其實不容易
但是你就要靠各種方式
去了解一下這一個部分
這個就是剛剛提到的
整個經營團隊狀況
第四個就是他的財務
因為財務還是最基本面
就是說他的營收投資
他的成本
這個部分是不是有按照他的
Milestone在往前走
很多人都知道AI是很重要的
但常常不知道從哪裡開始
所以院長常提到就是
懂用管件四個階段
不知道可以跟大家分享一下
企業跟個人該怎麼一步一步的來開始運用AI
我分兩部分
懂用管件主要是針對企業
我們說AI轉型的時候
一個企業首先要懂AI
這個不僅老闆要懂
員工也要懂
所以我們常常懂AI說
AI 什麼是AI
然後現在進展到什麼程度
什麼可以做 什麼不可以做
這個一定要有完整的掌握
懂AI這件事情我常跟大家分享說
有時候你需要了解一下AI的原理原則
但是你不用太技術細節
所以有時候從應用面來看
我就跟大家分享了
AI是什麼
就是人工智慧
什麼叫人工智慧
就是人工做的智慧
人有什麼智慧
簡單講就是眼耳鼻舌身意
眼睛會看
耳朵會聽
鼻子會聞
舌頭會講
然後鼻舌身
身體會動
然後意就是推論推薦
眼睛它現在已經可以做到說
好像我們的千里眼一樣
甚至比人還銳利
做瑕疵檢測的時候
甚至你現在拍照片
就給他這部車
他就會告訴你說
這是哪一個公司的車
然後是哪一年出品的
甚至你可以繼續問他說
這家公司的經營狀況如何
他就會告訴你
耳朵現在他不僅會聽
聽了之後還回答你
聽了之後知道你的意圖之後
還會想想看說
怎麼回應你會比較好
現在的客服很多就是在做這個事情
現在的很多的agent
就是可以做到專門應付三無客人
什麼叫三無客人
我不知道富方真業有沒有這樣的客人
就是無理就沒有禮貌
常常來罵人
還有無恥
我是老客戶你應該給我免費
這無恥還有無聊
這個Nora晚上有沒有空
一起喝個咖啡
無聊客人這三無客人
他聽到了之後就會開始回覆
然後知道你的意圖
然後的適當的話術來回應
比如說聲就是機器人
現在只是在電腦螢幕上面動
可是接下來的
如果它能夠直接指揮機器人的話
我想接下來可以運用的就更廣泛了
所以眼耳鼻舌生意
其實就在這樣子的一個範疇之內
你就享受它的應用範圍
在組織裡面這叫做懂AI
那用AI在公司裡面產銷人發財
哪些或者是在從原料進來一直到出貨
一直到客戶那邊
找客戶 完成買單
然後終身客戶服務
這種客戶旅程的過程當中
到底哪一段AI可以用上去
然後AI跟人怎麼協作
這個部分也需要知道
好 這是懂 然後用
再來管 管就是說
其實AI有時候你用不當
你的資訊會洩漏
或者是說
這個可能把不當的資料
就是資訊的汙染
或者是幻覺
或者是說你放到雲端去
然後就被人家洩露了等等
就是說資料
資安或者是剛剛講的偏見的問題都要管
有時候回答亂回答
可能這個Promise
不應該Promise的事情
所以AI一定要會管
我們知道叫AI治理
最後就是建
就是說如果你是一個中大型企業
你一定會想要建一個自己的腦
比如說富邦腦
你要建的時候
到底要建什麼樣的知識
可以做到什麼樣的事情
那這些都在建AI的時候
有一套方法論要去處理
所以這叫做懂用管建
對這是
那個人當然
第一個當然就是
你每天就是要用
然後嘗試各種嘗試這樣子
我覺得這個是
沒有別的方法
就是每天試
然後每天的去學說
怎麼樣更好的在你的工作上面
當然很多人都會說
那到底我的工作上
如何用AI能夠用得更順手呢
其實我覺得
你要從幾個地方角色
你首先你要先去盤點
你到底在你的工作裡面
比如說我在一個月
或者一個禮拜
我每天的到底都做哪些工作
把它全部列出來
甚至把它的流程
把它畫出來
畫出來之後
那你就去思考
哪些流程
可能AI做比你做有效率
舉例來說
他查資料
或者是出一個出版
就是Initial的Version
它可能比你厲害
像Idea
你只要來做決定來選就可以了
舉例來說
所以我說你一定要把你的工作先
然後你再看看說
那現在的AI哪一種工具
來做這件事情最有效率
也都可以去Try
這種就是一個Try and Error的方式
去帥
其實這種東西就是用習慣了
你就會非常熟悉
沒錯
所以我們就是每一天都要好好的去用AI
才會知道如何去駕馭它
那最後做決定的還是人嗎
所以未來的話我們要怎麼樣
培養比AI就是更有的重要的智慧呢
你這個其實是大哉問
為什麼呢
因為我們說要比它更有智慧
其實它都是專家了對不對
不過我剛剛不是一開始就有提到說
我們應該培養的能力
第一個是提問跟定義問題的能力
第二個就是辨識它的答案的能力
辨識完我們要能夠取捨
要能夠做決策
然後最後要承擔責任
就是在這四個地方
其實是人機協作上面非常重要
你知道說你的weakness
你不要去跟他競爭他最厲害的
而是要去運用他厲害的
也就是就好像韓信
韓信點兵多多益善
我覺得AI有點這樣子的
類似這樣子
就是說你怎麼樣去運用
然後賦能自己
讓自己可以更放大
我覺得這是第一個
你應該要有的
所以我剛剛講說
在這個過程當中
你怎麼樣說
可以跟他做好人機協作
然後接下來
你有很多agent的時候
你怎麼樣能夠去善用說
你要去管agent的能力
這時候你就發現說
如何組織跟管理一個團隊
事實上這也需要經驗
說實在的
也需要學習
所以有時候我就在想說
我在大學跟EMBS教書
就會覺得應該怎麼樣訓練學生
才能夠培養他們在AI時代應有的能力
所以尤其現在99%的作業可能是AI寫的
因為我今年突然發現說
臺大跟EMV學生
期末報告的水準是歷年來最高的
這可能不是他們的水準提高了
是AI的技術能力提高了
那這個概念就是說
那在這樣子的情況之下
我們的能力應該就是
怎麼樣去讓這個報告更有邏輯
然後更符合企業所要
企業組織所需要的
或者符合他未來達成的目標所需要的
這個其實是在過程當中
要不斷不斷的去讓自己
在這方面能力越來越高
而不要全部依靠AI
到時候我們連基本能力都沒有了
因為都完全被AI取代了
所以我以前開玩笑
說以前我們沒有ALS時代
在整個流程裡面是
Human do the loop
就是所有的loop整個流程都是人完成的
叫human do the loop
可是AI時代我們知道有些重要節點
我們要去check然後要核准
所以human in the loop
最後我們希望說能夠提高我們的位階跟格局跟高度
變成human on the loop
但是千萬不要out of loop
被這個loop可以淘汰了
我覺得這個是非常重要
好老師那最近常常有人講一句話
就是如果你沒有參與這個AI的浪潮
那其實你就是BI
那老師想說這邊部分
你好像有一些不同的這個見解
那老師要不要跟我們分享一下
其實也不是不同的見解
是剛好有一個EMBA的學生
在吃飯的時候
他們就說有個老師說
我們這幾年
如果你手上的持股
沒有AI概念股的話
你就BI了
就是臺語的BI
那我後來回去想想說
什麼叫AI
就是人工智慧
那BI如果我們把BI把它提升轉換為Buddha Intelligence
Buddha就是佛陀
所以如果我們能夠把BI提升做佛陀智慧的話
那你就一點就不會BI了
為什麼
因為佛陀智慧其實告訴我們幾件事情
第一個其實跟這個AI沒有關係
剛剛提到我們AI會不會被泡沫
就是第一個人要覺醒
這個覺醒很重要
就是你一定要aware
說這個覺醒包含說
自己對自己
剛剛我們不是提到
周楚楚傷害嗎
我們一定要自我覺醒
企業如果要轉型的話
一定要先自我覺醒
老闆要自我覺醒
那第二個呢
是要看透
看穿
其實我們知道說
佛羅看透宇宙的真理
所以我們說
是不是可以透過各種方法
去了解整個趨勢的變化
能夠看穿這個迷霧
然後瞭解一下
這樣整個事情的一個真相
瞭解掌握AI的一個變化
你就知道說
其實AI
它所謂的泡沫只是股價的修正
而並不是一個大趨勢的一個挑戰
因為它的確是一個
改變人類一個非常重要的趨勢
那再來呢
波託智慧裡面還告訴我們一個非常重要的
就是要放得下
要放下
就是說如果我們過去成功的經驗
未來不一定可以複製
所以我們有機會的話
可以把過去傳統成功的方法
然後因為AI來了
我們應該有新的方法來做
最後就是同理
我們知道是AI可能會影響
不管是我們的
比較落後的員工
或者是失業的人口
這時候我們就要同理心
就是怎麼樣能夠
把這些人提升
可以賦能我們的同事
賦能我們的員工
甚至賦能更多
遭到AI衝擊的這些民眾
我覺得這是我們未來
需要提升跟努力
這就是我們佛陀智慧的
一個非常重要的體悟
那我們今天非常謝謝
這個詹文德老師
他跟我們分享了
AI的發展歷史
然後到了臺灣的傳統產業
那他如何運用AI
AI到底是泡沫呢
還是它是一個未來的趨勢
到我們個人該如何面對
那今天謝謝院長的來
那如果各位的觀眾
有任何的建議或是提問
請在影片下面留言
我們都會看
請大家按贊訂閱
分享我們的節目
今天謝謝大家
拜拜
掰掰